you know we can't get a knife no we
can't get enough of all the setups that
people have taken photographs videos of
right of their home draft rooms I can't
get enough of them gentlemen started
this
well the Giants started all Andy Reid
was the Ihram who landed on this
Plymouth Rock and even got a go Andy
Reid setup right so we saw John Lynch's
set up and I mean that setup is the goat
impressive and again we had before we
took a wager friendly wager you say he's
calling in right now from phone to in
the middle I said center phone and you
said left phone Chris on the Left
leaving phone right for me John Lynch
you could make one of the three of us
very happy which phone are you calling
in from right now I I had to had to make
a run to the grocery store I'm in a
parking lot and about to get mashed up
and go in there and brave brave the okay
all right so just give us a few minutes
of your time on your cell phone here and
parking lot of whatever a grocery store
I mean what a setup it is John John how
many it looks like seventh grades a
seventh screen three phone setup that's
what it looks like to me and I think you
know I I don't know as a player I think
you learn you know you prepare for every
situation that might be thrown at you
and so all I did I mean shoot we are in
Silicon Valley so we have this extremely
talented people in RIT our video
department and basically what Kyle and I
did is said we want to replicate what we
do on draft day we know that's
impossible so where we need to be simple
we we'd rather do that than be cluttered
and cut you know complex and and so we
kind of described that and that's
essentially how we're going to do it
we're going to have you know we involve
a lot of people in our draft process we
like hear from all our coaches our
scouts and don't they'll kind of live
and one thing we're calling the huddle
that's going to be one virtual thing
going on there's going to be another
room which is our draft room our John
McVay draft room which we call it as if
we're
our facility and there'll be that group
of people and then Kyle and I whenever
the draft is getting crazy and and
you've got people what do you what are
we going to do what are we going to do
we always leave and go to my office
which is adjacent to the draft room and
so we've got jails office so that's kind
of how we're living that's what all the
screens are for other screens are for
notes for our internal system and so a
lot of people I think what do you need
all that for that's that's why you need
it and you've got other teams needs and
such so a lot of information being and
our crew did a great job setting it up
and I just hope it all works come
Thursday in terms in terms of working
lots of conversation about the run
through the rehearsal draft that went
down on on Monday and the issues that
that were had there can you give me any
details on on how that went from your
perspective what happened well I think
it was I think it was a lot of a lot of
smoke much ado about nothing I think
there you know I the best way I can say
it over the weekend we kind of did in a
internal mock and it was the proverbial
I won't say it on air but you know what
show and write but you know Jon Gruden
when I played for me used to have a
great saying sometimes you got to do the
things you don't want to do so that you
can do the things you want to do and so
you have to kind of go through that to
see as much as you plan out in your mind
until you actually go through the
scenario there's issues unforeseen
issues and so that's kind of what
happened on the very first pick I think
you know everybody was here in them
Cincinnati that's had some technical
difficulties Jerry came on and I think
the whole league our demand and so there
was that but then right after that it
got very smooth and you know I think
that's why we did it they'll do more of
them today with kind of the IT people
but I think everyone understands that
you you do kind of have to go through
the process to understand okay here's
here's an issue and I think I really do
think it will be as smooth as it can be
come Thursday okay and the Jerry you're
referring to I'm assuming you mean Jones
because we heard from Albert Brewer in
the first out of our program from Sports
Illustrated that there was
mock Cowboys Bengals trade to throw
everybody in the deep end of this
rehearsal pool and so Jerry was the one
who was on the phone for everybody yeah
I don't want to be sharing in-house
information but yeah you know that's
pretty cool there's only there's few
people in this league you just call by
the first name it's like I know on Jerry
yes and everybody knows that you're
talking about so I screwed that one up
but yeah he did I always winner at that
League meetings wherever it is I always
get such a kick when he speaks up
because it's always entertaining right
why so look John I mean I knew you're a
Stanford guy you wouldn't be the guy
that problem with a mute button I knew
that you'd because that's what we're
hearing to that there was the general
managers on the phone and that people
didn't know in the mutant what-have-you
but that is kind of part of the drafters
there's talks you have that you
certainly don't want to have other
people here and I think the you know the
best thing they did I think mask and
6-foot distancing and all that but you
know all right
all righty I've got our head video guys
going to be about seven feet away from
me there in this whole process right and
if I if I get in a pinch he can handle
it there's a lot of fail-safes if you
know with our system if my house were to
crash number one I've got a generator
number two then it goes to Adam Peterson
Adam Peters has been along with me all
that Kyle didn't want any part of
turning in a pic so he's out of the loop
but you know Adam Peters goes and then
Ethan why our college scouting director
so there's all those fail-safes there's
also you can pick up the phone and call
it in and so I think they've kind of
insulated this thing with a ton of
different ways that you know if if
everything goes awry that we can all
function and and I really I do have good
confidence that it's gonna go not
without a hitch but I think it will go
smoothly so in terms of that though you
know just last thing for you John on
this subject
nothing insurmountable then from what
you got from the the mock draft or the
rehearsal draft for Thursday it's a
title stuff that can be fixed I do
believe that I really do and I think I
think it's gonna be entertaining I
really do I know I made the you know on
our media call yesterday
everyone is just craving for something
live the other night it wasn't even live
but it was something new the last dance
and you know during this time I don't
watch much TV because anytime you watch
and TV you should be watching film work
or making calls and talking with people
but that last dance I had to watch it
Michael Jordan's just been the guy for
me and like so many people and I think
there's a very similar feeling I can't
tell you how many people have reached
out and said we are so looking forward
to this I think there'll be a fun
element to see in people you know in
their own environment I'm outing out
where my in a guest house where my
parents come and where they stay when
they come where my father-in-law and I
just I wanted more space so I'm out
there and I do think it's going to be
fun and and we'll make the best of it
this is serious business this is you
know this is how you build your teams
but I think we also are mindful of all
the people out there that are really
hurting and hopefully we can take their
mind off it give them something else to
focus on and give them something to
laugh about and and and you know boo us
if they want from home and all those
things that happens with the draft I'm
into that John Lynch I'm into that
and in terms of the draft nothing gets
more exciting when teams move up move
down you have not one but two
first-round selections reports
everywhere that you you would be willing
to trade not one or both to move down
around what what is your what thought
process that you can share with us 48
hours before the draft about 13th and
31st overall John yeah that's accurate
you know last year we made we hedged a
couple things and one of those you know
our second-round pick was we sent that
to the Chiefs for D Ford our third and
fourth round picks we got a 5th back
from Denver but they you know those
those those picks were were Emmanuel
Sanders now so we have a big gap between
those two first-round picks and and and
where we're going and in the fifth round
and would we trade that know that helped
us get to the Super Bowl and have a real
good chance of winning it but there is a
big gap there so I think you don't pass
up a special difference making player
and if that's there at 13 we'll stand
pat but if not and we feel like there's
a bunch
those guys still left then yeah we're
willing to get out of there to accrue
some more pics but you know I think the
same can be said at 31 so it's kind of
fluid I love you know the old comment
John Madden used to say all the people
at Fox you know what what happens when a
game breaks out ever you can do all the
pre-production you want but then a game
breaks out a draft breaks out and we're
gonna we'll be ready for all scenarios
and looking forward to it well I you
know when you talk about game-changing
players I mentioned this to you before
and your previous appearance here on
this show and then when we when we've
chatted off offline that Deebo samuel is
the guy that everybody is looking for
now and in fact Daniel Jeremiah at the
combine came up with the phrase finding
debo that everybody wants to find debo
so you would know just how deep this
wide receiver pool is in this draft how
deep is it compared to what you've seen
before it's incredibly deep it really is
certainly in the this would be my fourth
draft in this capacity it's as good as
class as I see now you probably don't
have but how often do you have a Randy
Moss something like that but what you do
have Eric decosta I think said it well
you find starter in the fifth round I
really believe that to be true you know
you start watching in a lot of positions
it runs dry really quick I think we were
24 players in and you're still really
enjoying the quality and the other thing
I said this at the combine it's kind of
like pick your flavor - you want a big
guys there's those guys you want a short
quick guy they have that you want a
burner so there's a little bit of
everything depending on what you need or
what you tend to tend to like as a
franchise it is very strong class at
that wide receiver and that there is a
ton of depth there well I got a couple
questions for you John Lynch that you
know you can touch you can but I know
these are touchy potential subjects
certainly two days before a draft have
you gotten any calls about 31st overall
from teams you think looking for a fifth
year of control for a quarterback
have you gotten those calls John not
specifically that you know we you you
know a lot of these guys are your
friends and you talk to them throughout
the process right I would say that
yesterday is when you start kind of
actually making formal calls a you know
just kind of want to let
you know our situation so nothing has
got specific in that specific scenario
no that has it happened but you know
like I said often times these things
happen on on the day of the draft unless
you're talking about the first or second
pick they will happen earlier no I just
faith it's that some of that stuff
starts to happen here yeah no because
again that's a that that's one of those
sweet spot of real estate for two
reasons one if you're in 31st to 32nd
overall it means you want a Super Bowl
or you went to one and also you know we
you know that was a right around the
spot where Lamar Jackson mused the last
pick in the draft and the first round
and you know teddy bridgewater as well
and you clearly have a quarterback your
own which leads me to my other question
here my colleague Deion Sanders was so
open at the combine about how Tom Brady
wanting up in San Francisco for
Garoppolo would be a perfect spot and
the Niners never said a word
you stayed Pat didn't do anything and
didn't did you and the rest of the 49ers
think about making a public statement at
any point on this very subject John you
know it's interesting because there were
a couple factors in that Kyle and I had
just made a statement at the combine
stating how much we believed in Jimmy
then these rumors come out and you know
the truth of the matter when you're
talking about and you got to be careful
up here because a lot of people up here
think the greatest player that ever
lived is Joe Montana so I'm careful
always to say when you're talking about
one of the greatest quarterbacks of all
time with Tom Brady of course you're
gonna have some internal discussion and
then you hear rumors that a he you know
he'd like to come home that kind of
thing
so of course Kyle and I have discussions
you know but the cool thing rich that
that we shared with Jimmy is that you
know we forced ourselves we're always in
to get better and so you look at
everything especially a situation like
that but within a day or two Kyle and I
looked at each other and said you know
what we really like what we have in
Jimmy we love everything that he brings
and we really believe it's a long-term
answer and so
that's that's you know I would tell you
we're more convicted than ever about who
our quarterback is and Jimmy Garoppolo
really excited about
despite the you know the challenges of
getting better without a traditional
offseason that he can do that the guy's
done nothing but when since he's been
here a lot of people try to pick his
game apart for whatever reason all I
know is the guy wins football games and
he's a tremendous teammate very talented
young man and I think his best football
still ahead of him so we're as committed
to Jimmy as ever and we've had those
discussions with him that's what was
important we didn't believe you know if
you start chasing every rumor out there
and making a statement on it then you're
doing that all the time and yes this was
a bigger one the important thing was we
had talked to Jimmy and told him exactly
what I told you yeah and you know we had
a manual Sanders on when he was after
he'd signed with the Saints and I asked
him about the final pass the Super Bowl
that you know was was intended for him
and he had every opportunity to
essentially and he's a veteran so you
know veterans know how to say something
without saying it he could not have been
more full-throated in who Jimmy G is is
a leader and who he is as a future you
know stud quarterback and that he's
already proven it I mean he couldn't
have been more effusive about Garoppolo
and he's not even on your team anymore
John well anybody who's been around and
that's just the you know you get a lot
of comments and I often think of the
best teammates I've ever played with not
the best players but the best teammates
and you know Derrick Brooks is one that
comes to mind Champ Bailey they tend to
be the better player but that's
something that players when I'm talking
to him all that I don't know if I've
ever had a better teammate and you just
talked about Emmanuel not throwing him I
mean the one thing Kyle will always tell
you John as a quarterback you have such
opportunity all the time ten times a
game that throws someone he was supposed
to be at 11 yards he wasn't Jimmy never
once since he's been hair has done that
every time he puts it on himself and
that's what gives us a lot of confidence
and
you know we've challenged him we think
there's places and and and that's coming
from Kyle places in his game where he
can improve and the great thing is Jimmy
embraces those and and we're going to
try to get that that best out of them
and we think he's already been
tremendous so you know I would leave it
with that where's convicted it as ever
about about him being our quarterback
and leading this this organization into
the future John I appreciate the time
are you sitting in a parking lot getting
set to go get your groceries for your
family I really appreciate it before I
let you go one last thing about that
shot of your office I could not help but
notice what appears to be an original
Leroy Nieman of the catch on your wall
is that an original Leroy Nieman of the
catch on your wall yeah that's that's a
great call we have a executive assistant
um to to Prague Marat day and she came
up one day and she said my parents were
friends with Leroy Nieman you know
there's about I don't want to I forget
what the number is there's very few of
them right Leroy Nieman did it and she
gave me one and full disclosure that
hasn't been hanging in my guest house
but it's in the draft I didn't want to
do it but my daughter came in to dad you
need something niners yeah so I put I
put up the catch Dwight was one of my
favorite people that's obviously such a
historic play in this organization so I
thought it was fitting to have it there
and it's been cool to look over at that
that's the kind of player we're looking
for and and and Dwight Clark and Leroy
Nieman I mean like if they really that
is I mean that all the technology up in
your in your in your spot right now that
could be the most valuable of them all
on that wall John that's pretty good
John thanks for the time man best to you
and your family and your you're one of
my favorites I really appreciate the
call I mean that to everybody out there
thanks a lot really thanks again and
good luck with the draft thanks for
doing it that's John Lynch I think it's
John Lynch right here on the Rich Eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch
right here